On a laissé tomber des
stationnements incitatifs pour
réduire les coûts.
- Prolonger la ligger la liggere
jusqu'à Anjou.
- En préparant cette annonce,
tout le monde savait qu'il y
avait du scepticisme dans l'air.
va tu se faire. Oui. Quand?
- Tant qu'ils ont pas commencé
à construire, on a des réserves!
CHANTAL ROULEAU
ministre déléguée aux Transports
- Je vous assure qois-
ci c'est la bonnne!
- Quelques rires jaunes, dans
la salle, puisque la première
annonce remonte à René Lévesque,
en 1979. C'est finalement
un demi-us tard,
en 2029 que la mise en service
est désormais prévue.
Au total, cinq stations verront
le jour. La nouveauté du projet,
c'est le futur terminus.
ès à la station seront
construits de chaque côté
de l'autoroute.
Une manière de mieux desservir
l'est et de ne pas trop empiéter
sur les Galeries d'Anjou, ce qus
de millions de dollars.
ÉRIC-ALAN CALDWELL prés. conseil
d'administration de la STM
- Le chèque est dans la malle.
Bravo! Là, on creuse.
- Même si on creuse déjà
dans le secteur Pie-IX, pour
connecter le SRB et la future
station, l'appel pour faire
venir un tunnelier qui parcourra
6 km, principalement sous
Jean-Talon, est prêt à être
lancé.
Le patron de la STM dresse
la liste des bénéfices.
25 600 usagers supplémentaires
en heure de pointe, dans
la section du prolongement
seulemenseulemenseulemenseuleme,
5300 automobiles de moins sur
les routes. Et pour la planète,
c'est 25 tonnes de GES de moins.
VALÉRIE PLANTE,
mairesse de Montréal
- Le prolongement de la ligne
bleue, qu'on annonce
aujourd'hui, ça démontre
de façon très... très réelle
ce que ça donne quand tout
le monde est autour de la table.
- Une allusion aux embûches
dans la planification du REM
de l'est.
Quant à la question du budget,
6,4 milliards de dollars,
ça ne doit plus être un frein,
selon Trajectoire Québec.
SARAH V. DOYON, dg,
Trajectoire Québec
- On s'inquiète pas vraiment
du prix des infrastructures
routiè il faut refaire
Turcot, faut refaire Turcot,
puis personne s'inquiète
du coût, alors en transport
collectif, bien, si ça coûte
6 milliards, ça coûte
rds puis çrds puis çrds puis çrr
des retombée9<Ok/+/ues
très importantes.
- Aucune station de métro
n'a été inaugurée sur l'île
me si on ne compte plus
les annonces officielles
similaires à celles
d'aujourd'hui, tout le monde
veut croire que cette fois,
fectivement la bonne.
Ici Mathieu Prost